we now would like to analyze the force
law on an idealized spring force law
called Hookes law let's begin by drawing
a ideal spring connected to an object on
a frictionless surface so we'll draw our
object we'll draw our idealized spring
this surface here is going to be
frictionless and this is a wall and
we'll draw it like that and now what
we'd like to do is to introduce the
force law for spring force law which
will be called Hookes law so the way
we'd like to analyze this is by drawing
two pictures our first picture will have
the spring at an equilibrium picture so
let's draw the wall again and let's draw
the spring and our object and this is
called the equilibrium picture so I'll
write equilibrium picture and now what
we'd like to do is draw a picture a
dynamic picture at some arbitrary time T
so here we have a dynamic picture at
time T and I'll draw it in a second so
we draw the same object and now we're
going to move our object to some
arbitrary position in this case the
spring has been stretched wall
frictionless surface and now I'm in
position to choose a coordinate system
so what I'll do is I'll choose my origin
at the edge right here this is called x
equals 0 I'll show it in the dynamic
picture and my coordinate function for
the object here I'm going to refer to
that as X of T now notice that this
coordinate function is also an
indication of how much the spring is
done just displaced as far as directions
go we'll have an axis
and this is our plus X direction so
usually we indicate that with a unit
vector uh-huh
and now Hookes law is the statement that
the force on the spring that the force
on the object F is proportional to how
much the object has displaced which
represents either the stretching or the
compressing of the spring so it's equal
to minus KX I had now what does this
minus sign mean well this is an example
of what we call a restoring force and
let's look at it as a couple of examples
when X is positive that means that the
object has been pulled out from the
equilibrium position the spring is
undergoing tension it's being stretched
apart the molecules in this spring that
comes to tooth the spring are being
pulled apart and there's a restoring
force inside the spring this is an
atomic force in nature that's pulling
the spring backwards
hence exerting a restoring force on the
object so this force is in the minus I
had direction it's restoring in that
direction I'll draw the force like that
now suppose we drew another picture
where the spring is yes the object is
pushed in compressing the spring so
let's draw once again a diagram and
let's show the spring under compression
from our equilibrium position now here
we have again that X of T but in this
case X of T is negative and when so this
is extension so we'll call that case a
and case B when X is less than zero it's
under compression
and then we see that with X negative and
the additional minus sign the force is
in the positive direction and so in both
instances the force is a restoring force
back to equilibrium so the restoring
force whether you're under extension or
compression is always bringing is
pointing let's just call it is the
direction of the force is towards the
towards the equilibrium position and
this example of a restoring force is
also only proportional to X and so in
that case we can add the word linear
because it's just to the single power X
and this is an example of a linear
restoring force and this is a model for
an ideal spring now this constant K is
called the spring constant and the units
of the spring constant if you divide the
units of force by the units of distance
so we have SI units our Newton / meters
and that's the measure of the spring
constant